And now for the answer to our quiz.
Generally, anything you can measure can also be turned into post condition,
and if at some physical condition, then it's typically very easy.
The audio level must not exceed 80 db.
While assuming we have a way to measure the audio level, which any descent
audio software should have, yup--this is easy to turn into a post condition.
Turn this into a post condition and you will save millions and millions of ears from damage.
Next thing, the animated catch should walk like a real cat. Ah, real cat.
If there ever is a specification of what makes a cat a real cat,
I would be very, very delighted to see that.
I'm pretty sure cats know precisely what to do and what not to do.
For everybody else, that remain a mystery.
Under specific atmospheric condition, the sunset simulation shall produce a green flash.
Lo and behold, that's what a PHD student at my department did.
He was specializing in computer graphics and his PHD thesis was perfect sunset simulation,
and indeed, in reality under specific conditions,
you can have a green flash during a sunset for just a second.
I think this has been witnessed by only a few hundred people
and only banned on film twice so far,
and well having green or some amount of green in an image--it's actually pretty easy to check.
So I am pretty sure he also had a post condition that were done and show that he was successful,
and finally response time shall be below 10 ms.
That's straightforward. Time is something that's easy to measure.
This can also become a simple post condition.